foreign
[Music]
now
I do want to do a jababa London game or
two with the white pieces because I did
release that course and I'm not doing
this to shill it out I just want people
to be aware of this opening and to be
aware of the work that I did on it so if
we get white we're going to do a jabal
London if we get black we're gonna do
our standard stuff so since the YouTube
video starts right now I'm just gonna
repeat what I said to my twitch stream
which is that uh one or two games I want
to do a jababa London kind of introduce
all of you to uh the basics I have a
course on the jabab London that is out
and out updated with more extensive text
annotations link will be in the
description I promise I won't keep
mentioning it we're actually just gonna
play a game so the jababa London is an
opening we've already played exactly
once on the speedrun we tried to play it
a couple games ago but we Face D4 G6 and
they're the most sensible option the
most principled option is to play E4
this is the starting position of the
jababa London this is what you're gonna
get probably 75 to 80 of the time at
least at most levels when you play D4
and Knight C3 most people know to play
D5 here other otherwise black risks
getting move ordered into a French or a
perk so a lot of people they go G6 or
they pre-move and then white plays E4
and typically you know most people don't
play the perk so you know black already
gets move ordered
so our opponent taking uh taking his
time trying to figure out what he wants
to play and G6 is on the board this is
the line that most Kings Indian and
grunfeld players end up choosing because
it is the most similar I mean it is
essentially a grundfelt setup in the
sense that black plays all the gruenfeld
moves right D5 Knight F6 and G6 of
course in contrast to the grunfels our
Pawn is not on C4 and this leads to a
fundamentally different type of game
here the idea is incredibly tactical so
bortek and I when we were preparing the
course we checked a couple of different
setups here and we came to the
conclusion that the most testing and the
one that causes the most problems to G6
players involves quickly pushing up the
H Pawn which sounds like you know
something you'd play in a bullet game or
some sort of gimmicky line but in fact
it's it poses very serious practical
problems Arjun aragaisy has played this
in OTB chess he's beaten all of the top
players with the setup and it's
legitimately annoying so don't think of
this as some sort of gimmicky you know a
line that you could play in one game uh
this is a forever type of idea and after
E3 we immediately start running the
h-bond up the board with the move H2 H4
and if you're not experienced in this
position or or with this idea which does
reoccur by the way in several different
openings I'll show you some examples of
an early h-man push which is legitimate
for example in the Dutch one of the best
lines involves quickly pushing the
h-bond we do want to play H5 and
sacrifice The Exchange on H5 and I'll
expand on that afterward our opponent
has played the main move which is H5
immediately stopping the progress of our
Pawn
now we respond by continuing our
development and I'm not going to take
too much time here to illustrate the
moves I'll do that mostly after the game
we play Knight F3 what I will say is
that it appears that the situation on
the king side is completely Frozen like
after black castles which is which you
just did there will never ever be any
chances to attack but that's actually
not true
sooner rather than later sooner than you
might think we will be in a position
where we will be able to play the
typical move G4 try to force Black's
Pawn off of H5 and then push our own
Pawn forward to H5 another incredibly
common attacking technique that you
could see in a sicilian you see this in
dragons very often or white just throws
the kitchen sink at black and the only
idea is to open up as many files and
diagonals as possible and then the
pieces is essentially infiltrate now in
this position again there are a couple
of options there's Knight to B5 uh
inducing Knight A6 there's Knight to E5
but Sasha and I settled on a move that
prepares long Castle which is ultimately
where we're going to Castle we have a
Pawn on H4 so rarely in the G6 lines you
Castle short it's not unprecedented but
95 of the time uh you Castle to the
queen side and you get a fascinating
game opposite side castling attacks on
opposite sides and our claim is that
White's attack is simply more effective
and
not necessarily is the game going to be
decided by an attack just as likely that
the game is decided by you know a battle
in the center of the board and that
seems likely given our opponent's last
move C5 so C5 is a typical move in most
queenspawn openings and it's
particularly sensible here because we
have a knight on C3 so in the regular
London system you often meet C5 with C3
here we can't solidify the pawn quite as
effectively but there is
you know on the other hand A major
benefit to developing the Knight to C3
which is that the Knight of course aims
at the D5 pawn and very often C5 is
simply met with d takes C5 and that's
what we're going to do right now we're
going to take this Pawn
we're going to take this pawn and you
might might say well aren't we giving
away
you know central control and we are to
an extent but the pawn on D5 is now
under very serious fire
and we can actually capture it on this
move Knight Beauty so our opponent seems
very very confident I have to actually
remember if this is the line
this is I will put it this way a lot
more Theory than most people at this
level tend to reproduce now I'm pretty
sure we can take this other Pawn oh but
then black takes and goes Bishop takes
B2 wait a second let me think about this
for a second
Knight bd7 I hope I didn't mess it up
already which by the way I will do uh
very often even though I I did the
course it doesn't mean I remember
everything all the time and I'm not
ashamed to admit that nobody does hmm so
we could play Knight takes D5 but then
the problem is
black plays Knight takes D5 Queen takes
D5 and Bishop takes B2
and then after we move our Rook it's a
complicated position but black can drop
back to C3 with the bishop so I'm not
enthralled by that option there's also
B4 but B4 runs into the Tactical Knight
E4 and then we lose at the very least I
think in exchange on A1 which is not
appealing at all I think D takes E5
might have been wrong
but let's see if we can make the most
out of this Knight A4 there's again
Knight E4
wow
clearly our opponent has studied this
um very very carefully
and it's not the end of the world I mean
even after we allow Knight takes C5 it's
fine it's not like black is winning or
anything
and one of the typical setups in this
line of the jibava basically involves
moving this Knight away from F3 so
playing a move like Knight to E5
and then basically putting the pawn up
to F3 in order to prepare the idea that
I had mentioned previously let's give
that a shot let's play 95. it's for 95.
I'm assuming our opponent will take on
C5 because that seems to be the only
sensible move
he probably has my course that's
entirely possible I'll have to check the
course I mean C5 is definitely analyzed
there's just so many so many lines that
we've looked at that I I pretty often
get confused
um and I will ultimately study the
course more carefully myself okay Knight
takes C5 our Knight is nicely positioned
in the center but now the second
component of that move is to play the
move F3 just a second
and F3 is played for two primary reasons
the most important is that we are
preparing an eventual G2 G4 and H4 H5
and I'll show you some if we don't get
to carry this out during the game I'll
show you some examples of how the
effective this can be in this line
um the second is a more positional
reason we are controlling the E4 Square
so we are not permitting blacks either
of Black Knights to jump into E4 which
would be very very unpleasant and you
should kind of intuitively understand
that Knight E4 was a serious threat
positionally at least
so we're trying to restrict the mobility
of the knights and it's important to
understand that yes black has Superior
central control but that's not
necessarily a good thing because the
pawn on Z5 is a serious Target and by
castle and queen side we are also adding
an attacker on the D5 Pawn so the
position is incredibly sharp and we have
found through our investigation of most
online games that people just they
struggle in a lot of different types of
jababa positions because they're
unconventional and that's one of the
biggest perks of playing this opening it
leads to Fresh positions where people
are lost at sea like the usual
principles just do not apply in many
types of positions so you can really
that's why you can score so many really
quick victories okay Bishop F5 so in
many of these lines Bishop F5 is in fact
met with G4 H takes G4 and H5 and that's
a risky idea it's an interesting idea we
could try it I'd have to calculate it
for a bit the alternative is to play it
safe and simply castle queenside castle
Queen side and continue our develop and
go after the D5 pawn and then maybe play
G4 on the next move
is Bishop E2 yeah Bishop E2 of course is
a candidate move to prepare G4
but Bishop E2 is a little bit passive I
think Bishop E2 is a little bit passive
we often don't need to play Bishop E2
because the point of G4 we're happy to
sacrifice the pawn actually we want to
sacrifice the pawn because that opens up
the files give me 30 seconds to make
this decision
Bishop E2 also by the way very much on
the table
okay as much as I know the tactics Andes
among you want us to play G4 I don't
think I think it's premature I think
it's way premature it might work it
might work but this is not what I want
to promote on the speedrun right I don't
want to make gimmicky moves that you
know that set traps
unless we're losing
so let's Castle
so we're threatening the pawn I mean we
are we are threatening to play Knight
takes D5
and we will take that Bond if given the
opportunity of course it's a little bit
dangerous because this bishop is
x-raying the B2 pawn and we have to be
very very careful
we have to be very careful because the
Knight on E5 is also not supported by a
pawn which means it's a little bit more
vulnerable so potentially if black moves
the Knight away from F6 basically we
have to react carefully to whatever our
opponent does and we have to Super
carefully identify not only the
immediate threats but also the potential
tactical patterns for instance if black
plays in this position Queen B6 which
probably might be the best move I don't
know that move in itself does not create
any immediate threats but it aims at the
B2 Pawn so later on if our Knight is
gone from E5 and our Knight is gone from
C3 we have to be especially careful
about tactics involving like a maid on
B2 and when you long when you have
episode side castling those two
processes have to always happen you have
to identify the short-term threats and
then understand how each of your
opponent's move impacts the sort of
long-term tactical patterns because that
helps you nip things in the bud before
you blunder them yeah of course it's
it's risky like what we're doing is
risky but
it's fun and it teaches you a lot about
tactical positions and it's just not
easy for black to play this type of
structure we don't have to play G4 on
the neck okay Bishop E6 so that's a bit
of a passive mode actually likes to see
this move this this move is music to my
ears because not only does it not
accentuate the attack on the queen side
it essentially loses a move and it takes
the E6 square away from the Knight which
could have dropped back to E6 in certain
cases
so once again this this increases the
appeal of the move G4 which is now very
very tempting for me
it's still incredibly double edged but
it feels to me that now that we've
shepherded our King to safety it's a
good time to consider the move G4 we
just smash through in the king side and
this is the kind of move that you know a
GM might play without calculating that
many variations because our attack in my
experience analyzing this line of the
jababa has convinced me that in so many
positions G4 H5 just works all right
just it just opens up a bunch of files
and then our Queen from D2 this is a
crucial follow-up idea once we play G4
Our Queen has direct access to the H
file so when the H file opens up Queen
H2 could automatically create an
Unstoppable made threat on H7
so we could still play this positionally
we could play King B1 but let's go for
it let's play in the spirit of the
jababa London let's try G4 and let's see
what happens
and hopefully black takes of course
black could also ignore which might be
the best thing black could do here
well maybe we had time for Bishop I
actually dislike Bishop E2 because it
closes off the Avenue for the queen
right so Bishop E2 actually could end up
being counterproductive I actually would
not take on G4 here with black I I will
I will say I would not take on G4 here
but that's a very Advanced thing to do
to not take this pawn and to realize
that in fact black is stable on the king
side for the time being we're not
threatening anything
we're not G5 is not really a threat it
forces the Knight away maybe wins the D5
Pawn definitely G takes H5 is not a
threat because then the Knight
recaptures and that's also
counterproductive because it opens up
the bishop it hits the bishop on F4 and
we don't actually open up any
substantive files or diagonals yeah very
tough position Queen A5 very very
impressive play thus far by our opponent
I have to say but Queen A5 might be
inaccurate because it walks into
a lot of different types of tactics so I
actually like the look of Queen A5 for
us so what do we do
what do we do queen A5 what does Queen
A5 do well it doesn't do anything
immediately but it it pressures the A2
pawn and that is very very annoying
because we do not want our Knight to be
the only piece that stands between us
and Checkmate we want to be a lot safer
than that if possible and there is a
move which caters to the defensive needs
of the position this is a move you
should be automatically considering any
time that you Castle
which is of course King to be one which
is of course going to be one and let's
play it
um yeah let's play King B1
now as it turns out king B1 also poses a
hidden tactical threat which is
increases the appeal of this move for me
there is a devilish tactical idea that
we're threatening this move right now
and it wins a bunch of Pawns
yeah so another theme that reoccurs in a
lot of openings when the Queens are in a
standoff particularly on this diagonal
there's this idea of Knight takes D5
classic classic Discovery concept okay
our opponent
missed it but wait a second because this
is not as simple as it may seem we play
Knight takes D5 black can't take the
Knight because they lose the queen right
so after Knight D5 black has to play
Queen takes D2 you know so okay then we
have to take the queen and black of
course takes on D5 and block us up a
piece but there's the rub after Knight
takes D5 Queen takes D2 We can go on and
take the pawn on E7 another intermediate
move
and only after the king moves did we
recapture the queen on D2 and we're up
two pawns now in that resulting position
it's not as straightforward as it may
seem because that Knight on E7 is
virtually trapped and black could try to
win that night with Rook C to E8 for
example but I feel like tactically will
be able to find a way to evacuate
tonight my intuition says that we will
be able to find some move maybe that
counter attacks are maybe G5 to get the
D5 Square open for our Knight it doesn't
seem to me that black will be able to
win the Knight cleanly but it's you know
it's a little bit dicey but let's see
let me think
okay let's take the plunge
let's take the plunge I can almost
guarantee that black missed this move I
would be Beyond impressed if he saw all
of this and then found some way to trap
the Knight I don't think so
I really don't think so
no so this is an important Point Queen
takes D2 Knight takes F6 is a very
common blunder super common blunder
because black actually recaptures with
the pawn
okay and then the pawn attacks the
Knight on E5 you're assuming the black
has to recapture with the bishop then
everything is Chill
then everything is Chill but no black
takes back with a pawn and we lose our
Knight and I could probably show you
some examples of IRL players blundering
that kind of concept there is another
very important tactical detail that you
have to bear in mind it's actually in
our favor that The Rook on f8 that The
Rook is on f8 and I'll explain why after
the game funny thing is we could also
play Knight takes G6 and cash in our
Knight for like a bunch of Pawns but
there's no need to do that now we could
do that you know in an emergency
scenario let's recapture the queen
let's recapture the queen
and of course this Rook is also hanging
don't forget that when a lot of
exchanges happen it's uh very easy to
it's a very common time to blunder
because a lot of people they forget to
sort of update their perception of the
board for example yeah The Rook on C8 is
a piece that would often be blundered
okay Rook da great move
I think that is the most testing move so
let me think about this for a second
of course the downside of taking on d8
is that after Rook takes d8 black is
threatening Checkmate on T1 so he forces
us to burn another Tempo on moving our
Bishop there
and I don't see a great spot for the
bishop and then our Knight could end up
in a lot of trouble
although I do have a really interesting
idea
so it involves taking on d8
and then playing Bishop to H3
then I assume our opponent will attack
our Knight with rookie 8 and then I
wanted to go G5 but
yeah I actually like the look of that
it's super hard to calculate and
yeah but the problem is in that
resulting position we might win Black's
night back but black is going to take
one of our pawns back and I want to try
to keep our two extra pawns if at all
possible
I don't like Knight takes G6 I don't
like Knight takes G6 because black just
takes and after Knight takes G6 King
moves and again a rook is hanging so we
can't I mean we can take a f8 but black
takes the Rook on D2
so when all is said and done we don't
really gain anything
so let's go for my idea because we're
running short of time
we're running short of time
so Rook takes C8 Rook takes the other
there's also Rook to D4 which is what's
called a collinear move it's where you
put a piece on an intermediate Square on
the same file so when two pieces are
staring at each other you make a move
that's on the same file but it's not a
capture
so Rook D4 also looks very interesting
to me actually because then already
Knights hd6 becomes a serious threat if
that Knight takes G6 becomes a becomes a
very legitimate idea
but that also has to be calculated and
it's a bit of a head spinning line
geez there's a there's some crazy
tactics here okay let's go Rook D4 let's
take the plunge
let's play Rook D4
extremely complicated position and we we
actually are short of time so I might
have to do my you know put on my GM hat
in a couple of moves and really hunker
down and play
yeah John Nunn who is a British
Grandmaster he developed I think he
coined the term collinear move they can
be some of the hardest moves to
conceptually to realize that exists
because in your mind you're like well if
two works are staring at least they'll
either have to move the Rook away from
the file or I have to take but there's
like two intermediate options there's
the idea of Defending a rook and I did
consider them of Rook hh2 to protect the
Rook didn't like it but then there's the
collinear move where you move a piece up
on the same file but you don't capture
on d8
so Double Take on G6 and then take the
Rook on f8 is that a threat sort of I
mean what do we get we get we get two
more pawns so we're we're gonna have a
grand total of four extra pawns and a
rook for two pieces that's a big
material advantage so yeah Knight takes
G6 is definitely a move to seriously
consider it's not one-sided that we
benefit from that by the way because
Black's minor pieces are incredibly
active in this position
so giving black more of them and giving
us less of them well I guess we're not
giving black more minor pieces but
removing our own minor pieces from the
board may allow black to optimize the
activity of his own pieces
okay Rook D4
also what kinds of tactical patterns am
I noticing here well one of the Hidden
patterns that I think most people have
forgotten about because the Queens are
off the board is that the king can still
be checkmated in certain cases so if
black plays H takes G4 the move H5 is
still often very effective in the end
game because all we really need is this
Rook on H1 and notice the Knight on E7
it's a very bad piece it's our worst
piece but it's also doing one productive
thing which is that it's taking away the
Escape score from the black kings so if
you're big into like mating patterns and
mates Anastasia's mate is is I'm
smelling some Anastasia's mates here if
we can get the H file open
if we can get the H file open
and I know people have a lot of
questions about specific moves that
black and play let's wait for our
opponent's response and then after the
game will you know dive a little bit
deeper into like some of the moves that
are concerning
a lot of people
okay she is played
all right so Knight takes G6 is still
possible as an emergency option that's
kind of a bailout move
but H5 is very very attractive to me
very attractive to me and it just feels
like we emerge ahead in the resulting
pandemonium
but maybe not maybe I'm maybe I'm
miscalculating I'm largely using my
intuition it just feels like H5 is the
move let's just do it what do we have to
lose let's just do it
so if the Knight takes then we play Pawn
takes G4
if the Knight takes on H5 we play Pawn
takes G4 that was my idea at least and
the Knight on H5 is pinned we win the
night
okay clearly I'm missing something
because our opponent played this
instantly
so maybe there's something I failed to
see let me think about this so F takes
G4 as as much as there is going on
you know everything is protected for the
time being like the bishop on F4 is
Untouchable because the Knight is pinned
the Rokon Z4 is protected by the pawn
the Knight on E7 is not being attacked
so it's safe as well
I don't see it I think we can just play
F takes G4
I think we can just do this
yeah now not only are we threatening to
take the Knight but when we take the
Knight we're also going to be
threatening the follow-up H takes G6 and
that's essentially checkmate with the
Rook on H1 opening up yeah so Bishop
takes G4 here is a way to try to gain
some material back it loses on the spot
Bishop takes G4 loses I mean I already I
think black is lost
but what would we do after Bishop takes
G4 let's see if you can avoid tunnel
vision
let's see if you can avoid tunnel vision
count chronix is I think black missed
that the Knight was spent entirely
possible Bishop takes C5 yeah but this
doesn't help at all this doesn't help at
all
yeah Knight takes F7 and Rook takes d8
so in response to Bishop takes G4 black
would have relinquished their defense of
the F7 pawn and then we would have
snapped The Rook off the board and
forked the other rook in the king so
Bishop takes C5 obviously
well we don't take the Knight that would
make no sense because the Rook is
hanging we first have to take the bishop
with check
then when the king moves okay F6
so now let's try to be very precise
because we can take literally anything
we want to take right now
this is the fun part this is where we
get to choose which pieces to capture
now the simplest option I think absolute
simplest option is Knight takes G6 check
because on top of everything else we
also win The Rook in the corner
more less accurate would be G takes H5
because then black plays F take C5 and
you might be attracted to the the idea
of delivering a discover check but the
king actually runs away to F6
so if you follow the line GH Fe HG King
G7 Rook H7 it's not made because the
King has F6
why not Rook takes d8 because then black
plays Rook takes T8 and we could also
play by the way Bishop takes that oh
Bishop takes F6 check might be even
stronger
yeah Bishop F6 check might be the best
move actually I just realized that this
exists because the Knight is pinned and
if the Rook takes we take d8 with check
and then recapture the Knight
yeah Bishop F6 or Knight G6 literally
choose your pick it's
totally winning either way where we win
a crap ton of material but let's play
elegantly in the spirit of the Jabba
we'll play we'll play The Elegant move
we'll play The Elegant move
yeah total Feast Rook takes F6 Rook
takes the a check and then of course we
pick up the Knight and it's very
important that the bishop is protected
it's very important that in the final
position this bishop on F1 is defended
by The Rook okay the rest is a matter of
technique it's impressive that our
Knight ends up in the same place it
started it's still on E7 it's perfectly
safe and now we can evacuate it through
D5 another perhaps sexier way to to do
this would be to evacuate it through G8
using some tactics I'm trying to find
the fastest win I'm trying to find a way
to mate here but I don't see it I don't
see a mate I think we should just play
it simple
and just go like Knight D5 very very you
know plain vanilla meat and potato chips
just get your night out of the danger
zone in your upper Rook not everything
has to be you know
tactically crazy well calculated you can
play simple simple chess especially when
you're up material
and then our night is maneuvering to F4
where it's on a perfect defended square
and it's pressuring H5
Rook F5 okay Knight F4
this is a very nice Outpost for the
night
and we're going to eliminate Black's
last past spawn
yeah this is resignable completely
resignable
okay we can play again I always say this
when we reach these types of positions
which is that you know that there's
going to be like five or seven or even
more equivalently good moves it's
totally a matter of taste how you
convert such a position when it's this
winning I like to go for checkmate and
go for more material some people uh they
put the emphasis on trading pieces so
something like Bishop D3 would be a good
move I want to deliver the check on you
one because I want to hunt this King
down
Maybe unsuccessfully
but this move feels right
um
okay well
what do we do here Bishop D3 now I don't
see a mating that end unfortunately
I just don't see a mating pattern here
we don't need lift right now I mean we
could play B3
could play B3 if you're paranoid but
there's no even hypothetical back rank
right now so black has no pieces left
with which to deliver the back ring mate
all right let's give another check
let's give another check
okay
King E7
and now I'm going to slide The Rook over
to H6
and I am going to put the Rook behind
the pawn
maybe The Rook H7 to follow and then
bring the bishop out one way or
something's going to give something's
going to go okay 94 the first thing I
see is that it aligns the knight in The
Rook so without further thinking let's
go Bishop D3
and force exchanges
okay Knight T2 checking obviously goes
to C1 in order to attack the Knight
simultaneously now again we have a
choice we can play Bishop takes F5 and
simplify but if we wanted to go for more
material if we wanted to just win all of
Black's pieces which is what I want to
do we go Rook G3
the only thing I would recommend is that
you you don't automatically just trade I
mean sometimes if you can win a minor
piece that's better
I guess because I guess black has Knight
H4 but then we go Rook H3 yeah no this
is not a trade I'm saying we could have
if we wanted to taken on F5 and traded
the Rooks that is a form of a trade it's
just an unconventional trade
we'll definitely have a good amount to
look at after the game
oh yeah Mr real country one okay yeah so
that's why we moved the Rook up
now our opponent resigns okay I
appreciate it all right
so let's first and foremost I'm going to
open up the course
and I definitely confused something I
definitely got something wrong in the
opening I can feel it because the
position we got was complicated and
interesting but it didn't feel like the
you know it didn't just have that sense
that it was the line we were
recommending
oh yeah I just uh I freaked out this
this is the main line I apologize to
everybody on YouTube I had a it's been a
long day I had a mental complete mental
breakdown the move here is 95. this is
literally the main line that we
recommend
um and we have some incredible analysis
here so I just
confused I just confused the position
for some reason I forgot that we don't
have to react to C5 we can just do our
thing and I'll show you some of the main
lines after 95 in a second
so
um a quick a quick sort of overview of
the G6 variation E3 Bishop G7 and H4 yes
indeed we want to play the move H5 so if
black for instance plays A6 which is a
move that we analyze we already play H5
we play H5
and after Knight H5 Rook takes H5 GH
Queen H5 not only does white have full
compensation for the exchange we believe
that Black's position
I don't want to say lost but practically
I think it's close to lust already
now why is that why why is white like so
much better here well there's many many
reasons of course there's like the
concrete reasons which is that which is
that D5 is hanging which is that D5 is
hanging
D5 has to be defended because that's the
center pawn and we're going to take it
with our Knight and a really cool line
is after E6 to defend the pawn we have
an amazing move this is such a lovely
move let's see who can find it that's
all I'm going to say is that it's a
lovely move you should pause it on
YouTube if you if you don't have the
course of course
White's a plan win some more material
and this is such a typical idea in these
types of positions
himself uh
kind of coined this move no G4S eh
Bishop C7 doesn't work just one as a
bishop but you're on the right track not
Queen G4 that's a one move threat black
and defend against that
so you actually can win the C7 Pawn here
yeah very good sussy Baca got it Queen
to H2 out of nowhere you build this
battery and it turns out black cannot
defend C7
because you can't move the pawn you drop
the Knight
now why is C7 important well this move
is good not just because it attacks C7
also the queen is very safe on H2 and
one of the other reasons that black is
in such trouble is that he can never
Castle black can never Castle because
the king is gonna get massacred on the
king side here with all these open files
and diagonals well first of all you can
play Bishop C7 Bishop takes B8 but even
if you didn't have that you could play
Bishop D3 Knight F3 Knight G5 you could
castle and put a rook on H1 and this
Pawn is incredibly weak so I don't want
to belabor the point here C6 is our main
move in the course
C6 is our main move and here white just
develops Knight F3 and if Knight D7
white already wins the game with Knight
G5 and look at this line Rook f8
now white has a very prosaic tactic
Knight to E6
attacking the queen attacking the bishop
but after Queen A5 there's an even
better move than Knight takes Bishop
check you go Bishop C7 and you actually
win the entire Queen because you're
threatening now Knight takes G7
Checkmate and black can't even get a
bishop for the queen because then you
win The Rook
so if you're a jababa player this is one
of the fundamental ideas that you should
be familiar with in the G6 line which is
which is the move H4 and this is one of
the typical ideas that I show in the in
the typical ideas database
now black of course has many ways to
respond to this move the most popular
move on Lee chess is H5 the second most
popular is in fact a castle kingside is
in fact a castle King site and as you
can probably guess the move here is H5
and now a ton of people walk into this
trap where they go Bishop G4 and they
say oh let me pick up this with a bishop
so that he can't sack The Exchange well
this is terrible because of F3
and you always have to remember that
when you fincated the bishop the other
Bishop doesn't have this retreating
Square so G4 picks it up
if Knight takes H5 we Analyze This in
tremendous depth but this is completely
one-sided position why does white is
crushing here for example C6 Bishop D3
F5 Knight F3 remember you just develop
your pieces and after Queen E8 hopefully
if you've been paying attention you
already know what White's move is you
already know what's white White's move
is it is in fact Queen H2 dropping the
queen away with Tempo attacking the
Knight and that Tempo is then generated
to Castle kingside and queen side and
quickly get a rook to H1 and even if
you're not experienced in this opening I
think you can be able to tell that
the attack on H7 the coordination of
White's pieces the domination over E5 is
totally disgusting here black is busted
it's like plus four so you're gonna win
a lot of games like this castles in H5
okay so on we go to our opponent's move
we also analyze H6 in the course we try
to look at almost every common move but
let's focus on H5 for now
um so now we continue with our
development Knight F3
our opponent castles Queen D2 this is
the main line of our course and C5 is
the most common move and here I had a
complete meltdown for for some reason I
forgot that this was the main line
and I played DC which is which is a move
that Bortnick and I analyze but it in
fact is refuted with Knight pd7 so huge
kudos to our opponent he did find the
correct response to DC which is not easy
Knight bd7 is not an easy move in my
opinion because it also seems to hang
the D5 Pawn
so it's just something that black has to
know and if black doesn't find ibd7 I
think white is probably better what is
the correct move instead the correct
move is to position the Knight on E5
which is exactly what we did in the game
except we did it after we played DC
which is obviously a concession right
you don't want to give away this Pawn uh
or move it away from D4 if you can help
it and after 95
Black's most common response
in this position is Knight to C6
at any point black can also play cded
that doesn't change all that much in
fact it allows us to later Play Bishop
H6 so the GMS play Knight C6 here and
now we execute the same idea that we did
in the game we play F3
we play F3
basically we combine the idea of G4 with
play on The Queen side another very
typical I wouldn't call it typical
another classic Concept in the chippava
is play on both sides of the board where
you set up attacking ideas on the king's
side but you don't restrict yourself to
just playing on the king side you also
aim for positional domination on the
other side of the board uh which is
which is pretty mind expanding when you
look at some of these lines for example
so if black plays cded which is the main
line usually black takes this Pawn at
this point
um Geary against Bortnick so Sasha had
this uh three title Tuesdays ago against
Anish giri who played the move Queen to
B6 and got a lost position in five moves
watch white of course castles Queen side
that's the whole point protecting D4 and
B2
now Anish plays Bishop to F5 and as you
already know what is white Smith in this
position who can tell me
what the time has come to do
X Glam course for the link to my course
G4 yeah of course G4 hgh5
now it's not intuitively apparent to
most people why this is in fact so
strong
and I could analyze this for an hour
there's a lot of concrete tactics here
one of the main ideas to remember is
that if black plays GF and ignores you
shove this Pawn down to H6 and you say
well this is counterproductive right we
want to remove the spawn from the board
and of course that's why you play H7
and if King G7 Bishop H6 is mating so
black has to take on H7 this is
absolutely an utterly crushing you can
actually throw in the move Knight 65
here and hit the queen and then of
course you get down to business Queen H2
G5 and the last hurdle that has to be
crossed this bishop on F5 has to be
eliminated if it's eliminated then
Checkmate on the H file is inevitable
and that's how you find Bishop D3
getting rid of the bishop black can
resign it's made it's made in like two
moves after H5 black has to respond to
this threat but there's not a lot of
ways in which black can do that if black
plays Knight takes H5 then you play F
takes G4 forking these minor pieces and
that's not the end of the line but it's
incredibly unpleasant for black if black
plays GH then you play FG continuing to
try to open up files on the king side
um
HG is just awful because it opens up the
H file and allows us to stick with Queen
on H2 and this is just winning for white
um probably more accurate actually is
even to go Bishop H6 here yeah Bishop H6
is just winning because the queen is
coming to G5 I mean you're threatening
600 different mates
so in this position our main move in the
file is
GTX H5 F takes G4 H takes G4 sorry
Bishop to D3 this is the clinical move
this is the clinical move and after
Bishop D3 Knight C3 everything is
finally ready for us to put a queen on
H2 so Knight takes D4 we come back to E5
first to centralize the Knight and
finally we move the queen over to H2
and black is in huge trouble rook dg1
and Knight takes G4 is coming Knight
takes D5 is a huge threat nobody on
Earth is going to be able to defend this
position
so this is uh examples of attacking on
the king side what about the queen side
in which cases do we transition the
focus over to the other side of the
board after Knight C6 F3 the best move
according to our analysis is not Queen
B6 after cded it's actually Bishop F5
and here G4 is premature as a good rule
of thumb you don't normally play G4
until you have castled queenside but if
you Castle queenside here then black has
this very unpleasant move Knight to B4
black has this very unpleasant move
Knight cp4 and now C2 is under Fire and
you don't want to go Bishop D3 and give
away the light squared Bishop which is
an integral integral piece
instead you actually play this move
which is not
intuitively apparent that it's good you
play Bishop B5
and you put pressure on the Knight on C6
now it's not that black has no way to
defend the Knight the problem is that if
black defends the Knight with an with a
natural move like Rook C8 and the same
thing by the way uh is happens in
response to Queen B6 if somebody has
read the course or purchased the course
let's see who can tell me what
incredibly thematic positional idea on
the queen side allows us to completely
freeze all of Black's play on The Queen
side after this sequence black is
helpless on the queen side
and it involves two steps
step one is to do what in this position
hmm
this is a purely positional idea don't
look for tactics
Knight takes C6 does win an exchange
excellent but it's bad
black and Sack The Exchange there for
compensation yeah you play Bishop takes
C6
and then you play
uh Knight C3 to A4
19324 I call this a Rubenstein idea this
doesn't have a formal name I call this
the Rubenstein idea over a game that I
have already shown on stream actually
quite recently but let me jog your
memory
um Akiva Rubenstein if you're watching
on YouTube and you haven't heard of him
look him up read his Wikipedia page one
of the best players of the early 20th
century never became a world champion
but probably the greatest positional
player of the of the early 1900s he
understood so many Concepts that people
of his time were totally clueless about
and that included blockade and weak how
to deal with weak pawns okay
why do I call this a Rubenstein idea
because this idea of blocking the C5
Square when there is a C6 pawn it was a
very famously applied by Rubenstein in a
game that he played
that a Russian chess coaches really
liked showing this game to students
we have this position in the game
Rubenstein against salve
and as you can probably guess you you
can guess what Rubenstein played here
the way this Pawn structure arose this
was an iqp isolated Queen Pawn
Rubenstein traded on C6 reaching What's
called the hanging Pawn structure
and now of course he played what move he
played Knight A4 and the point of all of
his subsequent moves is to create a full
blockade on the C5 Square why would you
do that well because you can almost
think of the C6 Pawn as an isolated Pawn
which it sort of is not technically
because it does have a neighboring Pawn
but pawns don't go backwards so C6 I
guess is a backward Pawn that's how we
would refer to it properly
and your technique for dealing with some
of these backward pawns is the same as
with an isolated Pawn you blockade the
square in front of it to make it
impossible for for your opponent to
eradicate the weakness of that pawn and
watch what Rubenstein does Bishop E3
now if you're paying attention the next
move should be very natural to you Rook
C1 now he's got three different pieces
on the C5 Square Salvage tries to get
some counter play with Bishop G4 he
sends the bishop away
and then finally everything is ready we
can occupy the square with our Bishop
and here he puts into practice an
incredible plan
so he puts into and carries out an
amazing idea that made a big impression
on me when I was uh when I was a kid
this the next three moves or next four
moves it's not enough to blockade the
square in front of the pawn now you also
eventually have to win the pawn and you
don't win a pawn by simply block hitting
it you need to add a little bit of juice
to the C file so you might think well
let's play Queen C2 but leading with a
queen is usually not a very good idea
when you're stacking pieces on a file so
the ideal scenario
is of course to get the Rook from F1
somehow over to C2 for example and Roman
side finds a very efficient way to do
that he goes Rook F2
Knight D7 by Salve okay they trade now
already you have to be very alert
because black threatens to go C5 so
first he puts the queen on D4 again to
prevent the motion of the pawn now he
plays Bishop F1
to activate the bishop
and so in order to accomplish both of
these things with the movie three now
he's activating the bishop and finally
he is ready after the trade of knights
to move the Rook from F2 to C2 and he's
achieved his plan and with the two Rooks
aiming at C5 he can now push his beep on
up the board and basically tear black
apart on the C on the C file and he ends
up winning a couple of games all right
sorry he ends up winning the game in a
couple of moves
so there's a nice tactic that occurs a
little bit later after A6 he goes Rook
A5 so now that the pawn is on B4 you
don't need a piece on C5 anymore and
after Rook b8a3 Salve panics or the
rookie well not panics he's already lost
he plays Rook A7 let's see who can find
White's game-winning tactic this wins
material and this is such a poetic
culmination of his entire strategy
because well you'll see why it's an easy
move well I use chess space to find this
game fast I knew when it was played yeah
Rook takes C6 excellent
so you win the pawn it took him like 15
moves but he wins the pawn and wins
another one and he wins the game and
just uh eight more moves
so that's why I refer to this concept as
the Rubenstein technique where you
blockade the C5 square and the jababa
it's incredibly common across many
different lines
back to the speedrun game
so of course when we do this thing when
we play Knight A4 we're not restricting
ourselves from playing G4 in fact if you
follow the course
after Knight A4
the main line goes Knight to D7 okay
Knight to D7 trying to trade off the
Knight for me five you say okay I'm
happy to trade now you stick a knight on
C5 now you follow the rule don't go G4
until you've castled the castling is
perfectly safe black can't even put a
rook on the open file even that isn't
available to him black is lost here it's
actually lost like not exaggerating
because black has no moves and our next
move is just going to be either G4 or
the engine just says you have the time
to play Rook hg1 because black is so
paralyzed you can actually just prepare
G4 you you don't even have to sack a
pawn and deal with the tactics but of
course G4 H5 is also very very strong
here as well
um but this is a lovely idea Bishop C6
and that's why you play Bishop B5 and
that is why people who know what to do
actually move the knight from C6 so the
main line is in fact Knight takes Knight
because of this concept and before I go
on another line in which this is a very
common idea is the E6 variation which is
the most common move on Lee chess E6
here you play Knight B5
and there's a line where black plays
Knight A6 and basically goes C6
and
Bishop D6 this is a very common way to
play and here you gain an advantage by
playing Bishop takes D6 Queen takes D6
Bishop A6 ba and hopefully you can
understand the similarity here you're
not attacking on the king side but you
still have this incredibly weak C4
Square so actually you can play Knight
A4 right away our move is Knight F3 but
this is also possible
because you have the move C3 here
defending the knife another important
technique by the way to play C3 in
response to the check and again you have
this blockade on C5 the bishop has no
prospects and white is positionally
dominating
so this is one of the ideas that I
illustrate in the common ideas section
all right so we go back for a second to
uh this position instead of Rook C8 the
main line is 95 to e97 the course goes
on for like 10 or 15 more moves this is
an incredibly dangerous position for
black and we found some very very cool
ideas here
I'll just give you the next two moves
which are castles Knight takes C5 and
now not Knight takes D5 but rather you
go after Black's Bishop with Bishop H6
this is a super cool move Bishop H6 here
um which is which I think reinvigorates
the variation apologies first you go
Rook hu1 my bad you go Rook hg1 first
uh kicking the Knight away and then
after Knight C6 you go Bishop H6 and
it's incredibly incredibly dangerous for
blackened to analyze more you you can
get the course long story short I had a
brain fart and the move here is Knight
E5 not D take C5 and after Knight bd7 I
realized that immediately
so
again the problem here is that we can't
really take on D5 here we're much worse
because after the trade black takes on
B2 and everybody should understand why
this is bad for white Queen's coming out
Bishop's dropping back and we're not
going to be able to Castle Queen side
because we're gonna have to move our
Rook
so instead we had to do damage control
and go Knight E5 Knight takes C5 and F3
so we're doing the same thing it's just
we don't have that D4 Pawn anymore
Bishop F5 castles I think our opponent
is playing really really well up until
this point I think Bishop E6 is a really
really bad move
and I think it gives us an opportunity
to
jump start our attack I think if black
plays correctly here he's much better
and the key Insight that our opponent
had to make is that there is an easy way
to defend D5 but indirectly Bishop B6 is
so passive the bishop on F5 is an
amazing piece
so E6 yeah you don't want to go E6 here
because the bishop is kind of Trapped in
the resulting position
Bishop is kind of Trapped in the
resulting position and white has some
ideas like E4 d e and queen E3
hitting the Knight it's just a little
bit awkward
yeah Rook C8 I think the best move is
Rook C8
and what this does is that it it creates
an x-ray against the C2 pawn and against
the king Knight takes D5 is Unthinkable
because perhaps black has a game-winning
tactic here but even a simple move like
Queen A5 you have to sense that this is
just white is dead here because there's
way too many threats the queen on D5 is
vulnerable like there's a thousand ways
to attack it and this is just no good
it's like minus seven
um
the computer line here is Bishop C4 and
now simply Rook cd8 traps the queen this
literally traps the queen
um
and if white plays I don't know Queen D2
then you drop this Pawn but wherever
white turns you're gonna blunder either
the queen or you're gonna give up one or
you're gonna get mated if you play King
B1 again just Rook cd8 is winning so
this is an instructive you know really
appreciating why black is winning there
would will help you build your attacking
intuition we would have never taken on
D5 here I probably would have played
King to B1 and tried to escape the C
file but this is problematic I mean
after Queen B6 black is really aiming at
our King from all sides and here you're
really missing the D4 Pawn here you can
you can really understand why the D4
Pawn is so important because it shuts
the bishop out it shuts the C5 Square
out it disrupts the coordination of
Black's pieces without that pawn Black's
attack becomes potentially devastating I
mean the engine thinks white as
borderline lost here so I probably would
have played Bishop E2 and try to go G4
anyway
but black can bring the Rook into the
game and there's another problem with
the G4 which is that if you try to do
this here you just your pieces are so
uncoordinated and arcing is under such
fire that black just strikes first she
takes F3 Bishop F3 and now Knight ce4 is
incredibly strong
and we're just not fast enough if we
take it and we go first of all black can
take just with a pun
well I can take with a pawn and just win
the bishop on F3 so we just don't get
off the ground here because we're under
too much we're under too much strain on
the other side of the board here you
just take C3 and black wins
so
that's the issue is is black just is
able to coordinate faster than we're
able to get our attack started
yeah and white has to kind of hunker
down here and just try to defend best
move apparently is Queen to D4 trying to
you know create the preconditions for a
queen trade which would of course favor
us but black can step away with it Queen
A5
and if you play B4 the queen can Trump
back to B6 because you can't take the
Knight and white has made even more
weaknesses on the queen side of course
I'm mad at myself for confusing this but
that's why you should never be all that
mad at yourself when you're confusing
Theory and you're just starting an
opening I've been playing this for seven
years and you know I've analyzed this
line a hundred times and I confused the
move so it just happens right you're
human and the most important thing is
how you react after you realize they can
you confuse something you just have to
keep treating it like a regular position
of course our opponent gave us a new
lease on life Bishop E6 is really bad
and immediately I struck with G4
now our opponent plays Queen A5 which I
think is inferior to Queen B6 I think
Queen B6 is the best spot for the queen
in this position
and a very instructive moment because a
lot of people would automatically take
don't do that because you allow H5 and
now I think white has a huge attack
white is a huge attack
and that attack Works in exactly the
same way that as the lines that I showed
you with the pawn on D4 for example if
Knight takes H5 we chase the Knight away
and after Knight takes H4 we can even
play Queen H2 right away because we're
already threatening this devastating
mate on H7
if black plays GH then you always play
FG and you basically try to open up the
H file that's your ultimate idea this
should start to make sense to people
like the mechanism of attack should
start to make sense especially if you're
a sicilian player especially if you've
seen this idea before in the dragon
white has won so many easy games with
this exact Concept in the dragon I don't
have any off the top of my head
I don't have any at the top but even
some main lines actually involve
actually involve this this this idea
um and not just in the dragon and really
any opening where uh
where a fianchetto happens here's a
Fisher game that I that I found
here's a Bobby Fischer game from the
dragon that I found simul game
just off the top of my I mean not off
the top of my head I just did a search
and this is the first game that came up
and I think it's a suitable illustration
of this concept I just like to show
different openings where stuff happens
to the people get a better sense that
these are common patterns not just oh
this is this one time this is what chess
Improvement is all but oh and this is
perfect because it's going to give me an
opportunity to also show you why Knight
D5 is not a good move in certain
positions in this position there's a
queen on A5 a queen on D2
let's start over the reason I got
excited is because I'm also able to show
you why Knight D5 is bad in certain
positions
here after Queen D2 Knight takes E7
check the key difference is that black
doesn't have a rook on f8 so black and
play King f8 and attack the Knight and
you have to spin a Tempo capturing the
queen and black takes the Knight on E7
winning a piece as I was saying if you
have blundered like this the best thing
to do is Desperado sack the night for
another Pawn but black has you know a
piece for two Pawn so this is obviously
bad
now if you did this you you should
probably take F6 but this is just a
trade you don't really accomplish
anything with this so don't play Knight
C5 automatically you have to actually
test it concretely instead Fisher goes
H4 Black Goes H5 and you know the drill
G4 and H5
black plays GH now Fisher eliminates the
Knight which is a key defender of the
king side he takes G4 and he brings his
Rook to G1
and now the pressure down these two
files is totally overwhelming
Queen has shifted no Queen trade
and now as I was saying
he involves the Knight sorry
he involves the Knight via the center
and uses the Knight to deflect the queen
queen takes C7 there's Rook takes H5 and
the bishop on G4 is lost and then made
his following after that
so black can't take the Knight Knight
swings back and joins the attack and
then goes all the way back to E3 in
order to hit the bishop and after Bishop
D4 it's tactics time Rook takes G4 is an
easy liquidation into a winning end game
because if black plays Queen E3 he gets
ladder mated black can't take with a
pawn black has to take with a queen and
When the Smoke Clears Fisher's also
going to pick up the H Pawn this is a
completely winning end game two pieces
for a rook in this kind of situation is
black is dead in the water here
so you know not the greatest
illustration but it shows you that these
ideas are fairly ubiquitous G4 and H5
idea is to just open up a bunch of files
and then you bring your Rooks and your
queen into the game and often that leads
to checkmate okay C8 here the chief
difference is that there is a rook nf8 I
hope everybody understands that Knight
takes D5 Queen takes D2
um of course we didn't analyze
I suppose we didn't analyze HG but I
don't really want to analyze it I think
oh no we did look at it we did look at
it briefly uh clearly this is good for
what you can take a closer look on your
own if you're interested
but I want to get to the game okay C8
Knight takes D5
and of course Queen takes D2
so now to reiterate Knight takes F6
check folks allows e takes F6 and I
could go on a whole tangent about like
unconventional Pawn recaptures this is a
whole category of moves which basically
involves a situation where you assume
that the like natural capture is forced
but then suddenly like your opponent
takes with a pawn this is a very
straightforward illustrate here it's
obvious why you take with a pawn because
you win the Knight but there are some
incredible positional illustrations of
this concept
one of the most famous involves a game
between Vasily ivancic and vicianand who
played a match in 1992 in Linares and
this is an incredibly famous game I'll
just show you the start of it belabor
the point I promise but you'll I think
you'll enjoy this
um another game which my coach showed me
as a kid and it just made a big
impression on me for some reason uh this
is positional so don't don't expect
tactics here this is purely positional
in this position vasley ivanchik has the
white side of a sicilian right
and he decides that okay Black's attack
is quite strong
he decides the blacks attack is quite
strong here B4 is being threatened he
says let's bail out
and he says let's bail out
and he bails out with of course the move
Knight to D5 which is the move we're
talking about okay
Anand has no choice but to take the
queen and the whole point is that he
takes on that sixth check first black
has to take with the bishop he takes on
D2 and basically off for a draw this is
just an equal end game
what do you think we're missing in this
in this conversation what am I what am I
deliberately leaving out what happened
in the game
let's see who can yeah so Knight F6 GF
now why on Earth would you ruin your own
Pawn structure like this well there's
actually it is the top engine move and
black is better and there's a very
specific tactic or positional reason why
you play GTX F6 and it's all about the
next move let's see if anybody can
understand why GF is played and if you
find the next move then you it starts to
make sense very good Excel you deserve a
sub you got it the point is to play H5
am I looking though I don't get why why
is this so good and why couldn't you
have done this after Bishop F6 well the
second question is easy to answer if you
play H5 here well first of all D6 hangs
second of all white can just shut down
the king side with G5 and H4 big deal
so clearly you can't do either of those
things in this case G5 is not possible
the pawn is on D6 is defended you also
can't play H3
because black as tactics takes takes
takes
and H1 hangs so white actually has no
choice
but to ruin his own structure Evancho
played Rook G1 he didn't want to take
because in the resulting position black
develops huge pressure on H2 and can
also push the pawn down at F5 and start
developing pressure in the center
so he goes Rook G1 he gives black an
open file and now another incredible
move Bishop C4
this is another move which like wow
you're weakening all the light squares
for white white doesn't have a knight to
put on those light squares
and if white trades Bishops then black
opens up the B file and black is also
threatening to move C3 and Rook H3 and
White's pawns are super weak and the
whole position just falls apart for
white the whole position falls apart for
white and that's what happens in the
game Ananda infiltrates H3
then he brings his King out to the
center and the most important thing to
understand in this entire equation is a
that pawn structure is overrated I say
that often and the reason I say that is
because you cannot just look at
instructions say well this is better
this is good it's visually very ugly but
Black's pawns are incredibly well
defended all of them by either the
bishop they can also be easily defended
by a king from E7
so the bottom line here is that g takes
F6 is not as radical of a move as it may
appear
because in fact this structure arises
pretty often in a night Orphan Black is
fine and you get massive King side
pressure he wins the game in the end
yeah in the Rouser this this happens
quite frequently
um I I could spend longer on this game
but I don't want you know I don't want
any speed run video to go longer than an
hour
so let's finish off by taking a look at
whether our opponent could have found
something more testing in this position
Rook takes D2
Rook C to d8 in whoops sorry
in response to Rook C to E8 probably we
would have taken on G7 and that is why I
actually think King H7 is a better move
I thinking H7 is better because now you
can play Rook ce8 and we don't have
Knight takes G6 or King h8 was
incredibly sloppy it was super sloppy
King H7 was the move and in this
position I had to find the key move
because otherwise we lose our Knight and
I said this during the stream so you
guys should know what move I was
planning here the move is G5
counter-attack in Black Knight
if the Knight moves then well we can
evacuate our Knight to D5 here we should
probably take first
and then the Knight safely evacuates to
D5
what should black do well probably black
should play rookie seven and and snag a
pawn remember we were up two pawns so
now we're just up a full Pawn in the end
game and white is winning I mean we're
better we're up a pawn and I don't think
black has any realistic compensation
uh so
that's what we were planning in response
to rookie eight now let's go to the game
our opponent played the sloppy move King
h8 which gave us additional resources
now if black plays rookie eight now I
think we would have taken on G6
now we would have definitely taken on G6
because in the resulting position I mean
just look at this we have a four on one
for God's sake I don't know Bishop B5
then G5 our pawns are just running black
over
this is this is completely winning for
white
so this eliminates that option Rook d8
happened
and here I was actually really proud of
this move Rook to D4 because it keeps
the tension
and it keeps all of the advantages of
the position while keeping this Rook on
a Ultra safe square right best square is
a square that's protected by a pawn
um and collinear moves another tangent
that I could go on I think we've gotten
enough for this game
so just keep this in mind right Rook to
D4 collinear move putting the Rook on
the same file but on a defended Square
um I have a good example of collinear
move but uh I won't show one right now
and here I think our opponent makes the
decisive mistake yeah I I checked with
the engine and after H5 white is winning
on the spot this is over
this is game over because
If instead of Knight takes H5 which our
opponent played and here we can stop the
analysis because here we just win all of
Black's pieces
If instead black would have played GH we
would have played in exactly the same
way that we do in the Queens are on the
board we play FG
and black is busted because there's no
way to keep H5 protected if Bishop takes
G4 then again we don't have to play
Knight takes before we can just win The
Rook we can just do this
tunnel vision right avoiding tunnel
vision
if black plays Rook D to E8 which is the
top engine move we can actually play G
takes H5 and shove this Pawn down to H6
in black and resign
did I yeah I switched scenes this time
now I'm scared
and that's it so the Fatal mistake was H
takes G4 according to the engine black
has sorry not this move
according to the engine black has to
play King H7 which nobody on Earth is
gonna play and it's already bad it's
already bad we bring our Bishop out
black has no good way to attack the
Knight
so I would say that this decision to
play King h8 rather than King H7 is
really what did Black in had our
opponent played the immediate King H7 he
would have had the time to either hit
the Knight or play Rook cd8 and if we
compare this position to the one after
King h8 here black has this additional
move Rook de-8
and white doesn't have Knight takes G6
right we have to go with this move again
and black has Knight ft7 actually black
wins in exchange here because after the
trade
we can't protect our rook in our night
at the same time so we sacked the
exchange by defending the Knight and
white is still better in the resulting
position because we have two pawns and
we've got a lot of the dark squares and
we have D5 coming but black could
definitely defend here like I wouldn't
be confident I'd be Magnus in this
position
so
in any case this was a sloppy move and
then obviously allowing H5 and after F
takes G4 the game is the game is simply
over we take all of Black's pieces okay
so that concludes the analysis in
summary of course this was unfortunate I
messed up the move order I played DC
which is a big mistake because of Knight
B to D7 it's good to know uh the move
here is 95 I Illustrated some typical
ideas in the G6 variation hopefully that
encourages you to buy the course even
though I confused I got like the first
move wrong
the the course is in the link and uh
we'll play maybe one or two more jababa
games I'll show some more cool lines and
but it happens yeah you you know
everybody everybody confuses stuff from
time to time the important thing is that
we reacted well to it but if our
opponent had avoided playing passively
with Bishop E6
and had played Rook C8 we would have
been in very very serious trouble so
it's not an opening that you play if
you're not willing to take risks
uh but then again what are you doing at
the chess board if you're unwilling to
take risks thank you all for supporting
and subscribing
[Music]